hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game it's from round four
of this year's norway chess and it's a
richard rapport versus alireza ferruccio
rapporteur the only person to win a
classical game so far he won a game in
round one against aryanthari and now we
have another beautiful classical game uh
it features a lot of good times so i'm
sure you guys are gonna enjoy it uh
let's check it out and see how this uh
game affected the standings if if he did
you know in any way uh rapport opens
with d4 we have knight to f6 c for g6
knights the c3 and d5 so we have a
groomfield defense uh knight to f3 and
now bishop to g7 by ferugia we have
captures on the e5 knight captures on e5
and now the standard idea here is just
e4 we trade off the knights and then
continue the game uh with having a
strong center as white and black will of
course try to exploit those with some c5
ideas
but here we have bishop to d to a move
that's becoming increasingly popular as
black uh
isn't really having all that much
trouble equalizing in the absolute main
line uh here alireza castles and rook
the c1 and now it's uh well it's a bit
of a different story than the the the
absolute main line of the groomfield
because usually uh when you capture on
c3 white will capture with the b pawn
and then you are gonna further undermine
the center with with c5 as the white
rook would still be on a1 the bishop
would very much enjoy opening up the
center you would have the a5 square for
your queen in this case you don't the
bishop is on d2 so it's a
really a completely different game uh so
here we have knight captures and now
bishop captures so now again c5 makes
really no no sense here as the bishop
also covers the a5 square and this is
now very much sufficiently defended uh
already defends with knight uh continues
developing with knight to d7 preparing
b6 bishop to b7 and then he's gonna try
and play some like e6 queen e7 and bring
the rooks into the game uh e3 preparing
to develop the light square bishop b6
and bishop to e2 now there is one game
from 1999 where h4 was played but here
robert plays a bishop to e2 and it is
now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so bishop to b7 by
ferruja and now b4
b4 again with the idea of preventing
black from executing c5 which is
something black would definitely enjoy
doing at some point
since uh white does have a strong center
but now if you try c5 although it seems
like it's sufficiently defended not
really now we're just going to play d
captures on c5 and after let's say b
captures we're gonna eliminate the
bishop here king captures and now not go
for the pawn right away but first bishop
to b5 that's the idea now we're
threatening to win material here so
black has to do something maybe move the
knight and now we can just trade queens
queen catchers rook captures and now we
play c a b captures on c5 we're up upon
uh it's a it's a healthy pass pawn
whether it would survive or not it's
hard to say but uh white will definitely
be better here so uh uh alireza not
thinking about c5 at this moment uh he
continues developing knight to f6 and
now the rapport castles we have knight
to e4 going after the the dark square
bishop and rapper just brings it back
bishop to a1 and now queen to d6 the
rooks are now connected and you can
start bringing them into the game uh so
knight to e5 uh saying okay if you want
to capture you can double my pawns but
you're gonna have to give up your your
strongest defender here that is the dark
square bishop on g7 so of course we're
not doing that uh we have rook f the c8
now at some point we are hoping to
execute that c5 idea uh and also uh we
couldn't just capture the pawn on b4
because our own opponent c7 was saying
so rockef the c8 kind of makes um make
sense uh queen to a4 a very annoying
move defending this b4 pawn putting
pressure on a7 so this rook cannot move
uh and the just controlling a lot of
light squares here maybe knight d7 in
the future can be played knight the c6
is defended by the rook and by the queen
so a lot for alareza to consider we have
a6 here and now knight is coming to c6
so what do you play here uh of course uh
uh firuja not interested in giving up
his bishop pair as it's uh currently
cutting the board in half so it's a you
know a very useful thing to have uh b5
kicking the queen away queen to c2 and
only now uh bishop captures on c6
allowing this knight to remain here uh
doesn't make all that much sense as it's
hard to make a move with this knight
here the bishop without capturing the
knight even though it's really not what
you want to do uh the bishop is useless
the rooks have no way of entering the
game the knight controls the d8 and b8
and it you know it has to be captured
so bishop captures on c6 uh queen
captures on c6 we have queen captures
rook captures and now uh that rapport
has this beautiful c file open for well
semi open for his rook so the c7 point
is that is a target this rook is coming
to c1 and ferruja will have a hard time
defending this pawn so he starts by
opening up the position he wants to
activate the a8 rook as soon as possible
now bishop captures on b5 uh that's a
weird arrow we're gonna capture on b4
and have our uh rook ready to capture on
a2 so here bishop to d3 first attacking
the knight here knight back to f6 and
now only now bishop captures on b5 uh a
captures on b5 and now uh what you play
here we'll bishop the c4 we have to keep
an eye on
an eye on our pawn here and then we're
gonna organize an attack against the
black spawns here so knight the e4 now
hoping for knight to d2 to fork the rook
and the bishop here we really want to
eliminate the slight square bishop as
it's defending the a2 pawn so rook to c1
not allowing this fork still knight to
d2 is played and now bishop is coming to
asic so you don't have to defend upon uh
if the rook does not have access to the
pawn we have rook c to b8 the c8 rook is
under attack
and now uh rook one to c2 and going
after the knight here so here rook the
b6 by furuja trying to
make something out of the position uh
now attacking the the rookier but also
just threatening to win the bishop so
rook captures on b6 we have c captures
on b6 uh furuja ferruja forced to double
his pawns here and now bishop to b7
attacking the rook we have rook to a7
and now bishop to c6 uh so what do you
play here the knight is still attacked
and well the e4 square has been
captured by by the bishop so you can't
really go there uh you have to choose
between rook to c7 saying if you capture
my knight i'm going to capture your
bishop or the move that firuja played
and that is knight to b1 now you can
bring the knight back into the game via
the c3 or the a3 squares depending on
what white plays so here bishop to d5
again helping out with the defense of
the pawn here and now knight the c3
saying that uh well
are you maybe interested in my knight
here the problem is if you capture now
uh then we're not going to capture right
away we're going to play rook to c7 and
then you don't get to keep the pawn for
example a4 we're going to capture on c3
and after captures captures black has a
very very strong pass pawn here we're
gonna block with the bishop uh but still
it's uh opposite color bishop end game
not much hope for for either player here
so instead bishop back to b3 by rapport
and now rook to c7
we have f4 now not allowing any maybe
future knight to e to check ideas uh and
now uh e6 uh we have g4 and now bishop
to f6 the bishop now uh will be very
useful uh as at some point you're gonna
play b5 you want to play bishop back to
d8 and maybe shift the bishop all the
way to a5 if needed to help out with the
defense of this pawn because you know
here uh
your knight is allowed to you know
remain a guest on c3 as long as white
doesn't play a3 as soon as white plays
a3 that knight cannot remain there so we
we kind of have to figure out how to
keep an eye on that b4 square and the
bishop will do a fine job at that so g5
here pushing the bishop further back
bishop to a7 and now king to g2 now it's
time for both players to start improving
the activity of their kings king g7 king
to f3 and now h6 trying to undermine the
pawn chain but of course just h4 by
rapport and now uh the problem is uh you
would very much like to play something
like knight uh b5 try and trade the
rooks off but the king is very very
uh unluckily placed on this diagonal
although it's still kind of close but
make no mistake this here is is a bishop
pair from hell as you'll see so here
just d5 check and you would have
problems holding on to this game we're
going to start capturing on e6 the
bishop also captures that and it's just
a much better position for white so here
we have rook the c8 by all it is a
sort of a waiting move but then again we
are planning some bishop to d8 b5 and
bishop to a5 action in the future uh and
now the problem is also if you play a3
right away we can play rook to a8 and
now the bishop here might be a liability
so instead of a3 right away we have
bishop to b2
exactly for that reason and now b5 so we
have to do something i have to keep an
er to keep this knight on c3 uh and now
you could go for a3 but again a3 uh
for example h capture sage captures
we're gonna play rook to h8 now try and
get some uh activity with the rook on
the h file and after a captures on b4 uh
we can just move the knight tonight back
to d5 and it's still a
white is up upon of course white is
better but it's unclear whether this is
enough so here first we have rook to c1
uh i guess uh rapport wanted to
make sure what uh what alireza would
play in such a position but also it's
move 37 we still have three more moves
to reach time control and you know
making a move that doesn't ruin your
position and you know doesn't really
change anything but allows you to uh get
to that time control when your position
is better is definitely something to
consider so bishop to d8 now now bishop
to a5 is already possible and only now
a3 by rapport uh we have bishop to a5
and now a captures on b4 bishop captures
on b4 not allowing this diagonal to open
up and now e4
we have bishop back to a5 now b4 needs
to be played so you can once again
reactivate your bishop and now d5 so
this will create another pass pawn
we have e captures e captures and now h
captures on g5 h captures on g5 and now
b4 so now both players have a pass pawn
uh but this pass pawn will have trouble
getting through that bishop pair whereas
this past pawn
is a bit more dangerous so here rapper
starts pushing it we have d6 and now uh
you could continue with something like
king to f8 it makes sense to get the
king off of this diagonal but he starts
with rook to d8 and now rook to d1 made
possible as the knight is pinned so the
knight cannot capture the rook
uh we have bishop to b6 uh trying to
maybe maybe go after this pawn uh but
just d7 uh here robert says the pawn
will be very safe here but on the other
hand uh you you have to be careful king
f8 to e7 is coming and then this pawn
will be
uh
well will be rather weak so kinked fate
let's see what rapport had in mind with
this extra pawn push now comes rook to
d6 uh ideas like rook to f6 followed by
rook captures on f7 are possible and
also it comes with tempo the bishop here
is attacked so bishop to a7 and now
bishop the c4 so what do you play here
uh i if you allow
uh
well there's really not much you can do
here uh but if this spawn gets
sufficiently protected then it's it's
just game over for example if you try
kink the e7 right away uh we can just go
rook f6 there's
not much that you can do here and now if
rook captures on d7 we're just gonna
trade here captures captures k8 we're
gonna capture here and now the problem
is this pawn is on a light square so
king bishop to f7 just picks it up and
then we're left with two connected pass
pawns on the king side so instead we
have bishop to c5 here aloreza goes
after the rook here
rook to c6 and now bishop back to d4
and now rook to ca just threatening to
to win material here or of course if
rook captures we're going to bring a
queen into the game so here alireza has
to figure out what to play here and he
does not go for the only continuation
the only continuation is bishop to b6
you have to defend the rook uh and just
uh you know remain passive for for a
very long time uh instead he wanted to
play actively he played king to e7 he
was incredibly low on the clock uh but
you know uh that's the problem of uh
playing such a difficult fighting game
uh every move will require you to burn a
lot of time and of course you will you
will blunder at some point uh so uh this
move loses the game for alireza so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding well
basically the only idea that wins and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show it is bishop captures an f7 that's
the good stuff we removed the defender
of this pawn and now black's entire
position crumbles it doesn't really
matter what you play uh if the rook is
captured you could play rook captures uh
uh
rook captures on d8 uh
sorry
uh after bishop captures an f7 uh you
could capture the at the bishop here but
it doesn't help because we're going to
capture the rook and then it's just game
over there's no defending this so what
you could play is what happened in the
game and that is king captures on d7
but it's not much better here we have
rook to c4 attacking the bishop here and
now everything is still hanging this is
hanging this is hanging this is hanging
there's no way to defend all of it so
here king the e7 was played the rook now
guards the bishop and attacks the bishop
here but just bishop captures on g6
and uh there is no way to keep an eye on
everything uh rook the d6 was played
attacking the bishop here but here uh
rapper just played rook captures on b4
and he was in this position on move 55
that alireza foruger resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here uh everything is uh you know just
bad for black uh white has two connected
past pawns if you if you capture on g6
we're gonna capture on d4 and there's of
course no playing this the the two pawns
are too strong uh and if you don't do
this well what else is there to do yeah
you know there's there's really nothing
you you could do here you play something
like knight to the b5
trying to
do something i don't know what does it
still doesn't make sense
the only move you can make is you know
trying to give up some pieces but of
course we're not going to do that so now
after rook captures on b4 on move 55
furuja resigned the game and rapport is
now not the only person who won a
classical game in the tournament but he
is the only person who won two classical
games in a tournament sounds weird
because this is a classical tournament
but so far we've only had decisive
results in armageddon games uh not not
including of course rapport's uh
games in classical so now he defeated
and this has done wonders for his
classical rating uh if you want to check
it out these are the current live
standings so not the actual standings
live live standings that get updated
every month as you can see arou overtook
uh some very strong players here he
overtook dominguez perez uh shahrukh
mahmud of temu rajab and maxim vashila
grav uh to claim ninth place so he is
currently uh rated ninth in the world in
classical chess and if he continues
doing this well in this tournament
because we're still not even at the half
of the tournament uh
well he might even you know uh catch up
to i don't know maybe maybe levon arun
in fifth place but it's not gonna be
easy it's classical chess and he he has
to avoid losing uh any games and he you
know if he wins two more games it's
really gonna be incredible for for his
uh performance and rating so we'll see
what happens uh of course now rapport is
leading the tournament he he is leading
the tournament ever since he defeated
tari in round one that three points for
a win in classical is just huge for the
tournament standings and now beating
alireza uh three more extra points for
winning the classical it's it's not
going to be easy to catch up to him but
like i said we're still not even at the
half mark of the tournament uh robert's
next opponent is yani pomnishi uh which
is you know never a walk in the park uh
so we'll see what happens i hope you
guys enjoyed this i would like to thank
john queenie uh matthew coleman rupert
hipkins uh david cheswick and david
kimura for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this amazing
tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day